herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
heute zusammen mit esi ewigkeiten ja
dass wir was zusammen gemacht haben
aber dafür ist es umso cooler dass wir
heute vorhaben ihr seht ihr auf dem
tisch vor uns zwei ferngesteuerte auto
[Musik]
erstmals zu prüfen sich mit den fragen
wie wir das so dass dann russland aus
meine farbe und wir werden diese beiden
autos nehmen und zu kampfmaschinen
umbauen sind zwei identische autos beide
sind sehr gut
wir müssen uns jetzt was einfallen
lassen wie wir innerhalb von 24 stunden
das auto vom anderen mit unserem auto
zerstören können also bei dem betteln
bei einem wetter gebäuden uns gar nicht
grösser unterhalten was der jeweils
andere vor aber ich kann soviel sagen
ich habe schon geile idee dass würden
nicht mehr so richtig erkennbar sein
wenn wir zum kampf kommen wir noch nicht
was ihr wissen müsst bei ist jetzt
gleichzeitig auf seinem kanal das video
online wo er seinen wagen um baut das
heißt es weht heute hier nur die ich
meine banken bauen und dann seht ihr die
tage das große finale wo wir
gegeneinander antreten werden auch sagen
können letzte wünsche ich viel erfolg
wie egal warum das jetzt wieder voll
möge der bessere verlieren okay leute
hier sind sich jetzt mit dem auto und
ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher was
machen wird ich werde auf jeden fall auf
feuer setzen also irgendwie ein
bunsenbrenner kaufen oder sowas und den
so auf dem auto montieren dass ich
gleich nach vorne feuer schießen kann
und dann probiert ist das auto damit
anzuzünden ich habe mir auch gedacht
vielleicht besteht eine möglichkeit die
leistung bis hin zu tun also
bunsenbrenner das wird so das herzstück
von meinem auto ein alu folie
beziehungsweise dünnes blech mit dem ich
so einen kleinen panzer um das auto
bauen kann schaumstoff um so stöße
abzuführen dafür hinter die alufolie
oder das blech und ich will irgendwie
mehr spannung welche videos gesehen wo
das übertrieben gut funktioniert und die
autos werden richtig schnell
deshalb probiere ich das ganze aus und
dann will ich vielleicht auch so was wie
nägel oder so suchen warum ich dass
diese fünf sachen in einem buch
aufgeschrieben habe fragt ihr euch
heute 9 volt insgesamt 4,8 gerade bei
dem auto das wäre fast das doppelte ich
weiß nicht ob ich versuchen sein
im schlimmsten fall kann hat auch mein
kabel dadurch kaputt gehen oder so ich
glaube ich versuch's aber wie wär's 20
euro ist eigentlich ein budget für ein
bisschen schwer schäfer vor
das sägeblatt dran ich lausche allein
schon die so gut durch den baumarkt ich
werde sie weiß wo alles ist und so aber
klappt nicht unterkriegen ich hatte
trotzdem einen guten kampf abgeben und
vielleicht gewinnen wir sogar heute
gewiss ist ein kleiner gasbrenner vom
90er wir brauchen auf jeden fall was
größeres pleite giftig unser trainer in
allen ausführungen und größen wollte
eigentlich aber nur das was kommt ist
ein power was darf man nicht so schwer
sein
allerdings muss ja nicht so lange
brennen unser fall wird ja nicht so
lange gehen ich glaube dass hier sieht
schon echt ganz gut aus muss ich sagen
ich schaue mir das was hier in der hand
habe kosten 25 euro und ist halt viel
kleiner als das hier das sind zwei große
flaschen und die kosten 18 95 aber ich
denke ich nehme das kleine einfach wegen
des gewichts darauf bauen wir uns so
eine hülle um das auto fünf euro kostet
es auch nichts gutem budget jetzt nehme
ich noch ein paar schrauben und macht er
quasi sony geld raus mit euch richtig
cool aussehen
jetzt 34 das geht risiken
hier sind meine einkäufe zwei batterien
eine zum testen und eine die ich kurz
davor ein mache dann hier die schrauben
die wir so durch das autoblech durch
schrauben weil hugo alleskleber also
panzer tape brauche ich auf jeden fall
bunt der bunsenbrenner insgesamt 44 74
jetzt habe ich alles zusammen ich mache
mir zu einem kleinen plan wie ich das
bau- und dann fange ich morgen früh an
direkt als allererstes das auto zu bauen
so soll hier ist das auto hier sind alle
materialien ausgebreitet die ich gekauft
habe und benutzen darf wohl sagen wir
fangen mal an und probieren ob meine
theorie überhaupt stimmt also dass man
schneller fahren kann mit dem auto
wenn ich die neuen volt batterien rein
mache erstmal müssen wir glaube ich ein
bisschen testen wie das auto überhaupt
fährt man ja ganz klar
die sind gar nicht genannt aber diese
servolenkung hier ist übertrieben laut
ogh muss vielleicht auch mal ein
bisschen
hier ist der originalakten hier ist die
neuen volt batterie ich habe ja immer so
kabel ab machen muss jetzt versuchen
diese materie anderen auto anzuschließen
weil dann hat es theoretisch die
doppelte power das klebt schon mal das
sieht schon was du nicht so ganz verbund
coach also hier machen aber es muss ja
auch nicht lange halten oder so sondern
es muss endlich einmal funktioniert das
ganze hier anschließen und oder glaubst
du vielleicht sind vielleicht leiht das
auch gar nicht sondern nur die pole
darin genau anschauen
okay leute ist funktioniert wir müssen
das jetzt irgendwie machen und schauen
wir dann mehr leistung haben aber
höchstwahrscheinlich ja ok
[Musik]
entfernt man das top cover vom auto wenn
man zuschauen wie viel eigentlich soll
übrig ist wenn wir diese ganze plastik
sagte der oben ab und wer glaubt weniger
gewicht desto besser hallo gibt hier
auch super 4 405 machen das jetzt auch
mal alles ab machen
ich hab das brauchen wir eigentlich gar
nicht wer das ist schön und gut
sieht irgendwie cooler aus zieht jetzt
schon so aus als hätte er sich etwas
gemacht oder die rede ist jetzt einmal
zu probieren wir haben eigentlich alle
dass wir es notfalls ein zweites mal
machen könnt ihr einfach hier entlang
probieren das auto zu schneiden ich weiß
noch nicht wie das wird auch ein
richtiger helden die sie hat
wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie eine flex
oder so das bild ist es nein aber ich
musste mich mit den sachen
zufriedengeben ich habe leute dave ich
übrigens noch da und hilft mir mit der
kamera die ganze zeit deshalb weg schau
dort wir haben jetzt gerade an
bezeichnet wie lange wir das aluminium
haben wollen probieren das jetzt einfach
zu biegen und zu brechen ja das
funktioniert wird befragt richtigen maße
wald alter also was wir machen müssen
ist vier punkte markieren für diese
halterung die zum glück vom auto selbst
dabei sind löcher einschneidender den
draufsetzen kanten und liegen und dann
halten wir unseren panzer theoretisch
fertig okay das siehst du siehst du eier
ja ich probiere es ausgeht einfach ist
da anders auch papst eingelassen um
eingeschränkt hätten
lass es einfach so und benutzt als
servierwagen für speisen denn jemand im
wohnzimmer stimmt ja gebrauch ist was
trinken
naja ok
nein das sieht so witzig aus anders wir
sind leute ich hab an den ecken
es ist so dreckig gearbeitet mit einer
eigentlichen holzwege glaube ich dass
aluminium durchgesehen
das sieht auch nicht sehr sauber aus
aber es wird schon seinen zweck erfüllen
und jetzt zeichnen wir die ecken an und
dann biegen wir das ding damit wir
endlich um so ein panzer hier fertig
haben
perfekt rein in die wolga
geil
sehr gut
nutzt aber es sieht sehr gut aus jetzt
will sagen ist allerhöchste zeit dass
wir den bunsenbrenner mal austesten noto
wie man das
dann richter sehen sondern sie zwar
nicht der absolute vorteil von der
ganzen sache ist dass jetzt auch creme
brulée zu hause machen kann
ja man die finishing touches beginnen
der sich bald mit edi und muss jetzt
auch den letzten sagten wir machen damit
mein auto einsatzbereit ist ich habe
einen satten festgestellt hermann ganz
kurz denn hier die neun volt batterien
also auch und dranhänge gehört und wir
sehen uns ausgeht sie mich da wenn ich
aber den standard akku tram 8
es ist auf jeden fall ein bisschen wege
power also weniger schnell drehen sich
die reifen ich habe jetzt nur
festgestellt
das ist echt ein problem und deshalb
kann ich recht die batterie nicht
benutzten endet es auch hier mal ein
paar zurückgriff funktioniert nicht gut
aber aus irgendeinem grund wenn ich die
neue volte die reinmache vor zurück vor
zurück
merck wird derzeit überlege ich gerade
ich muss halt wenn die bahn ist schnell
bleiben
das nicht doch mit dem standardakku
arbeiten werde wollte nur sagen kümmere
ich mich jetzt um den panzer und ich
habe diesen kleinen winzigen rohr
angebracht ist arbeit zu fahren aber das
sieht man etwa über liegen mitteilte
so die ersten beiden ist fertig weichen
wie es euch geht aber ich hätte schon
weniger lust hier rein zu fahren ist
auch richtig gut und ich würde sagen
leute wir sind auf einem guten weg
es ist fertig und ich muss sagen ist die
dritte welt auf wurde wir sind auch
richtig fest die die nägel das gute ist
wir halten sie auf die länge dieser
regel auch fern von unserem auto ich
glaube das war nicht richtig gute ideen
und zwar so günstig 130 oder sondern die
ganze nägel gekostet und damit haben wir
echt nice das auto die sache ist ich
habe mir dazu überlegt wenn mein auto
gegen mein auto abtreten würde würde
wahrscheinlich keinen kaputt gehen
bestehe hier
deshalb bin ich echt gespannt dass es
auch so zu bieten hat vielleicht noch
weiter auto so gut gepanzert dass keiner
von beiden den anderen zerstören kann
aber so oder so das battle wird über
krank wir müssen alle dabei sein an die
zuschauer von easy wenn die gerade von
ist das video kommt ich hoffe dass ich
eine chance habe aber ja ich hab mir
auch ein foto geschickt unglaublich
dieses foto hier ich will es nicht zu
lange zeigen und man sieht dass er sich
halt voll in den arm beschritten hat
beim bau seines autos und ich glaube er
mit seinem auto gemacht deshalb ist
irgendwas mit messers zu tun haben leute
das ist es auch zusammensetzen also was
soll ich sagen unsere autos fährt es ist
im rückwärtsgang ein bisschen langsam
aber dafür dass es so stabil ist und so
viel angriffs power mit sich trägt bin
ich übertrieben zufrieden also sehr gut
jetzt kommt noch der bunsenbrenner drauf
dann sind wir fertig mit festen jetzt
mit dem bus oder auch und dann treffen
es auch schon mit für den großen kampf
ich hab auch dieses ventil gefunden das
hat ein bisschen größere flamme deshalb
werde ich das einfach austauschen und
dann bin ich wirklich einen das bereit
ist zeigt euch jetzt einfach das fertige
auto und da sehen wir uns nicht video
wieder wenn es heißt dieser panzer gegen
aziz
man merkt schon gerade im rückwärtsgang
ist der wagen echten struggle aber ich
habe jetzt geht s gut klar ich glaube
leute wir sind set das ist unser kampf
mobil
man kann zwar fläche man kann zwar
designtechnisch vielleicht ein bisschen
was optimieren aber ich glaube wir haben
echt gute chancen gegen die zuschauer
unbedingt wenn ihr das jetzt sehen auch
ist das video an
wenn du bist du schon ein bisschen was
euch erwartet wenn ich bin hier antreten
werde
vielen dank fürs zuschauen das gerne
like damit wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder auch sagen macht's gut